David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 21st, 1946, at Camp Lohengrin, a camp for Baltic DPs...ah...displaced persons. The interviewee is [pause] the interviewee is Ms. Anna Paul, a teacher, forty-five years old, who is alone here. Ah...she prefers to talk Russian.
David Boder: [In Russian] Значит, госпожа Пауль, Вы мне, пожалуйста, скажите, где Вы родились? Как Вас зовут, где Вы родились?
Anna Paul: Я...
David Boder: Где Вы были, когда началась война?
Anna Paul: Фамилия моя Пауль. Фамилия моя Пауль, имя моё Анна.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Мне 45 лет.
David Boder: Да.
Anna Paul: Родилась я в Тарту.
David Boder: Это где это?
Anna Paul: Это Эстония.
David Boder: Какой город в Эстонии? Как русское имя?
Anna Paul: Город Юрьев.
David Boder: О, Юрьев! В Дорпати [примечание переводчика: Дорпат – это немецкое название города Тарту]?
Anna Paul: Да, в Дорпати.
David Boder: Это в университетском городе.
Anna Paul: В университетском городе, да. Там я училась в университете.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: В Юрьевском. Училась в Юрьевском университете, потом окончила педагогиум Таллиннский и все время служила. До момента...
David Boder: Служила где?
Anna Paul: Служила в школе учительницей, заведовала школой.
David Boder: Так. Народной школой?
Anna Paul: Народной школой. Шестиклассной народной школой.
David Boder: Хорошо. Ну,...
Anna Paul: Восемнадцать лет заведовала.
David Boder: . . . теперь, пожалуйста, начните с того, когда для Вас, для Эстонии началась война. Скажите мне, где вы были и что с Вами случилось. Не торопитесь, не сокращайте, а говорите как подробно, как Вы можете. [Пауза] Так, эээ...садитесь ближе и...эээ...[неразборчиво ].
Anna Paul: Так.
David Boder: Хорошо. И говорите сюда, в микрофон. [Пауза] Так.
Anna Paul: Когда началась война, я жила на месте своей службы не в том городе, где была квартира, где жил муж, не в Дорпати, значит, не в Юрьеве. Я жила по месту своей службы. Это...школа моя находилась на границе с...с Советским Союзом.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Войны в Эстонии ждали, я могу сказать, все, я могу сказать, войны ждали.
Anna Paul: Потому что в этом многие видели меньшее зло, то есть освобождение от большевизма.
David Boder: Так подождите-ка, я хочу...как...я хочу, чтобы Вы, во-первых, начали с того, когда Советы пришли в Эстонию.
Anna Paul: Да. И когда начали базы строить ещё, да? Это в 39-м году. Это ещё до войны.
David Boder: Да, да, да.
Anna Paul: . . . ещё до войны?
David Boder: Да, да, да. Именно для Вас, так сказать, перемены начались с приходом Советов, не так ли?
Anna Paul: Тогда ещё не начались перемены, потому что тогда ещё...тогда же войны ещё не было, да? Они начались и наше правительство их пустило и только тогда [неразборчиво ]...
David Boder: Ага, вот Вы мне об этом расскажите.
Anna Paul: Да. Значит, теперь...теперь мы знали...мы узнали из сообщения нашего правительства, что правительству Советского Союза нужны, боясь войны...нужны базы построить на границе своего государства, так как наша граница...эээ...значит...Эстония находилась на границе с Европой, как они называли. Но в 39-м году пришли и...эээ...стали строить базы.
David Boder: Так. Но не забрали власть.
Anna Paul: Жизнь наша...жизнь наша не изменилась...
David Boder: Вот как?!
Anna Paul: . . . у нас было своё правительство...
David Boder: Вот рассказывайте об этом подробно.
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Теперь так. Но всюду стала вестись пропаганда коммунистическая и кончилось тем, что мне приходилось очень часто быть - как заведующей школы - на всевозможных митингах. Я прекрасно знаю, как это сводилось дело. Знаете, по...по зову каких-нибудь...эээ...двух крикунов как-то совершенно настроение всего собрания менялось, часто многотысячного собрания менялось, и выносилось...выносилась резолюция, что такая-то область или такой-то край - они желают присоединения к Советскому Союзу. И, наконец, получилось так, что Эстония желает сделаться сама частью Советского Союза.
David Boder: Ну, дальше, значит. [Пауза] Вы говорите в этом направлении, так. Хорошо.
Anna Paul: Теперь что же я должна сказать?
David Boder: Хорошо. Значит, и так это продолжалось до каких пор?
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Ну,...
David Boder: Нет, мне числа не надо. Так это продолжалось до тех пор, пока что? Россия объявила...Германия и Россия...
Anna Paul: Нет,...
David Boder: . . . начали воевать.
Anna Paul: Нет, нет, нет. Тогда нача...тогда дальше продолжалось дело так: эээ...было...эээ...наше правительство было арестовано...
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Где бы подробности об этом не сообщались. Наши...президент Эстонии...эээ...Константин Пятс...мы не знаем точно, куда он был арестован.
Anna Paul: Как он был арестован, после уже рассказывали. Рабочие были...из тюрем были выпущены, собрались около его дворца, он был...он был арестован,...
David Boder: Эээ...какие рабочие с тюрьмы вы...?
Anna Paul: Рабочие с заводов. С заводов, которые были распропагандированы в нашей столице, в Таллинне, которая...
David Boder: Так...?
Anna Paul: . . . называется Ревель иначе. Так же были освобождены все заключенные с тюрем – и политические заключенные, и...эээ...эти...как они ещё называются...эти...ммм...
David Boder: [неразборчиво] уголовные?
Anna Paul: . . . уголовные. И вот они все требовали, значит, был такой громадный митинг, значит, требовали, что не...что здесь будет Советская власть, что президента больше не нужно. Дальше всё кончилось тем, что когда было новое правительство избрано, то это правительство поехало в Москву, прося – об этом я знаю по радио, потому что была передача по радио уже нового правительства – прося, и таким образом случилась революция в Эстонии, - прося присоединения Эстонии к Советскому Союзу. Эстония была объявлена 17-ой республикой Советского Союза.
David Boder: Дальше. Ну, [какой-то стук], что...что после этого случилось?
Anna Paul: [Пауза, очень тихо] Ну, жизнь при большевиках.
David Boder: Ну да. Так вот,...
Anna Paul: Прежде всего, начались...прежде всего так: ещё нужно сказать, когда вступали...когда базы...когда входили большевики, да...это было в июле месяце...
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . то у нас был такой слух, у нас говорили, что жизнь в Советском Союзе очень изменилась; что Советское правительство, оно совершенно не желает никаких репрессий по отношению к тем, которые иначе мыслят, чем они мыслят; и народ...эээ...народ встречал...ну, если не до...если не...даже, пожалуй, приветливо даже встречал народ.
David Boder: Угу.
David Boder: Дальше.
Anna Paul: С приходом Советской власти, [пауза] конечно, жизнь сразу колоссально изменилась. [Пауза]
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Должны были люди участвовать - принудительно – во всех митингах. Например, на одном из...на одном из таких громадном первым митингом в июле месяце мне пришлось быть в нашем городе, в Тарту...
Anna Paul: . . . где должна была все профессура быть,
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . все студенты быть, тогда ещё наша...наша полиция должна была быть, которая ещё в своих...в своей ещё форме шла; студенты должны были пойти на этот митинг,...
Anna Paul: . . . нести нужно было знамёна. Дальше, конечно, была организация там кухарок ресторанов, и ордеров ресторанов и так далее. Как раз митинг начинался в 4 часа. Я помню, что мы с мужем были в ресторане как раз.
David Boder: Громче.
Anna Paul: И обер должен был без четверти четыре убрать со стола и говорить, что...эээ...такими нехорошими словами, что: «Была спокойная жизнь, и она кончилась».
David Boder: Кто это говорит?
Anna Paul: Это обер ресторана сказал, что была спокойная жизнь, и она...
David Boder: Да.
Anna Paul: . . . кончилась; что мы должны куда-то пойти бежать, какие-то [неразборчиво ] взять красные знамена и куда-то пойти, сами не знаем; что «Была же жизнь ешё, что нам больше нужно» – это нам обер ресторана сказал,...
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . когда мы были с мужем в ресторане.
Anna Paul: Теперь, значит...встречали приветливо. Советские...когда входили Советские войска, эстонский народ встречал приветливо, потому что...потому что верили в то, что...верили пропаганде правительства, что никаких репрессий по отношению инакомыслящих людей не будет.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Потом многие думали так, что возможно будет и выезды в Советский Союз, ну, возможна дружба с большим народом.
Anna Paul: В это...в это наш народ верил. Но не прошло, знаете, может быть двух недель после их прихода, как начались акции.
David Boder: Да, угу.
Anna Paul: В числе первых был арестован также мой муж.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Причина его ареста...она никому до сих пор не известна, единственно...единственно, что он был человек очень интеллигентный, и что по своим взглядам он был...не был коммунистом. Он не разделял мнение коммунистов. И...
David Boder: А чем он занимался?
Anna Paul: Мой муж был химик по образованию.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Окончивший университет Юрьевский, он был химик, и он не разделял взглядов коммунистов.
Anna Paul: Он был арестован один из первых. Между прочим, судьба арестованных: это, знаете, хуже, чем кусок свинца или олова на дно, потому что никаких абсолютно сведений. И когда я после пришла и узнала, что муж был взят с одним портфелем, и я не знаю, есть ли с собой хоть подушка или одеяло, смена белья, мне сказали, что такого нет. Я больше о своём муже ничего не знала. Никаких известий, на все запросы в тюрьмы это были...на все запросы в тюрьмы мне...мне ответ был там, что такого нет.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Потом...
David Boder: А скажите, были там ревельские, были там эстонские коммунисты, которые помогали Советам? [Пауза] Были у вас свои коммунисты тоже?
Anna Paul: Конечно, были.
David Boder: Так. И они работали вместе с Советами.
Anna Paul: Конечно, были. Конечно, были, которые помогали.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Своего же народа. Безусловно, были.
David Boder: Так. Ну, дальше.
Anna Paul: Так и в правительство вошло...правительство же, которое было ими образовано...коммунистическое правительство, да...это же тоже было...оно состояло из эстонцев.
David Boder: Ага.
Anna Paul: Оно же из эстонцев состояло. Нашлись также коммунисты среди нашего народа.
David Boder: Так, ну, и что же потом случилось?
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Дальше работа стала, я могу сказать о своей работе...
David Boder: Все это главным образом я хочу.
Anna Paul: Да. Теперь конечно. Программы сразу стали меняться. Теперь таких предметов как Закон Божий – они относились к нему насмешливо. Меня иногда спрашивали моё мнение относительно Закона Божего, а я говорила, что этот предмет имеет высокое моральное воспитательное значение в школах...эээ...религия и мораль. Но, конечно, к этому только с насмешкой относились. [Пауза] Теперь, нужно сказать, что школа...она стала разваливаться. [Пауза]
David Boder: В каком смысле?
Anna Paul: В том смысле, что дети должны были...из детей выбирались шпионы, которые и за учителями следили, за каждым словом учителя следили и доносили об этом. Это я знаю...
David Boder: А скажите, при ревельском правительстве этого не было?
Anna Paul: Когда у нас эстонское правительство было – это никогда не было.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Этого никогда не было.
David Boder: А какие же были политические заключенные в тюрьмах?
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Коммунисты [удивленно].
David Boder: А...они коммунистов запирали.
Anna Paul: Не...наше правительство?
David Boder: Угу.
Anna Paul: Да, конечно. У нас не было свободы коммунистам.
David Boder: Ага.
Anna Paul: У нас не было свободы коммунистам.
David Boder: Well, является ли тогда удивительно, что коммунисты не давали свободу другим? [Пауза] Что когда коммунисты пришли, так они не давали свободу другим?
Anna Paul: Нет, так это вполне понятно, да?
David Boder: Угу.
Anna Paul: [неразборчиво ] Ревельское наше правительство было республиканское...у нас была республика...
David Boder: Ну, да. Я понимаю. Значит, полной свободы мнения у вас в Вашей стране не было при ревельском правительстве?
Anna Paul: Нет, это только запрещалась пропаганда коммунистическая, работа коммунистическая...
David Boder: Ну, да.
Anna Paul: . . . а мнение – пожалуйста. Но у нас газеты коммунистической не было.
David Boder: Ага.
Anna Paul: Органа коммунистического у нас не было.
David Boder: Ага. [Пауза] А как Вы считаете, это было правильно?
David Boder: Как [неразборчиво]...
Anna Paul: Я понимаю.
David Boder: . . . Я как американец спрашиваю, потому что у нас в Америке в каждом городе или в каждом большом городе коммунистическая газета.
Anna Paul: Да, понимаю.
David Boder: Well, что Вы думаете? Чтобы мы запретили это?
Anna Paul: Нет, я знаю, что это в Америке этого нет. В Америке полная свобода – это я знаю. Что в Америке полная свобода.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: И наш...и мы сейчас даже иногда удивляемся такой именно свободе и...и...и...поражает, когда...нет, некоторые люди выражают своё удивление по поводу такой свободы в Америке...
Anna Paul: . . . другие говорят, что...что американское правительство настолько...эээ...ну, чувствует себя, что ли...
David Boder: . . . сильным...
Anna Paul: . . . прочным, сильным, что они совершенно не боятся никакой другой пропаганды.
David Boder: Да.
Anna Paul: Вот на это у нас такие возражения есть.
David Boder: Ага. Ну, вот я только хотел...потому что...я хотел задать этот вопрос.
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: Ну, дальше, значит. [Пауза] Так.
Anna Paul: Теперь, значит, Вы хотели спросить меня именно о чем?
David Boder: Вы говорили о школе. Значит, что Закон Божий сняли,...
Anna Paul: Закон Божий сняли. И все значит...теперь всё сводилось...все предметы...скажем, все учебники мы должны были изменить. Все учебники были только...эээ...уже Советские.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Между прочим, такая вещь: была...
David Boder: А язык не изменили?
Anna Paul: Язык в школ...у меня видите...я работала в русском крае.
David Boder: О! И у Вас всё равно русская школа.
Anna Paul: У меня всё равно была русская школа.
David Boder: А какой же Вы Закон Божий там преподавали? Православный?
Anna Paul: Православный. У нас было русское население, где я работала и...
David Boder: Так. И у Вас был священник и так далее.
Anna Paul: Нет. Эээ...учителя у нас сами давали, потому что школа была...район отдаленный от города...
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . всё...было затруднено...с приездами для священника и учителю поручено было по...эээ...по рассмотрению школьного инспектора – поручено было самому изучить [неразборчиво] преподавать Закон Божий.
Anna Paul: Теперь язык. Язык русский, конечно, в школах. И оставался русским языком. В эстонских школах язык и оставался эстонским.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . потому что это была всё-таки эстонская...
David Boder: А Вы сами русская или эстонка были?
Anna Paul: Я сама эстонка по матери, по отцу – русская.
David Boder: Ага. И Вы преподавали в русской школе.
Anna Paul: Я преподавала в русской школе. Я заведовала русской школой.
David Boder: Ну, да. Дальше.
Anna Paul: Теперь дальше. Все...относительно учебников. Учебники все были заменены Советскими учебниками. Изданными оттуда, привезенными. Московское издательство было, Ленинградское издательство было учебников. Между прочим, наши учебники были прекрасные, которые издавались в Эстонии.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Некоторые из нас были...были Рижского издательства, некоторые были эстонского издательства. Материал был очень...эээ...разнообразный, интересный. Когда...
David Boder: Скажите,...
Anna Paul: [неразборчиво ] эстонские учебники...
David Boder: Да.
Anna Paul: Дети более развитые говорили: «Как скучно!» Дети говорили. Потому что знаете,...по, например, хрестоматии русской, по русскому языку кроме того, что по всем вариациям биографии...биографии Ленина там ничего решительно не было. Или, например, плач китайцев по поводу его смерти. Больше ничего не было! Единственно...единственно везде пропаганда. Теперь задачники. Всякая задача составленная – там только было на колхозы: на колхозные овцы, на колхозных коров и так далее. Это страшно скучно и страшно было все однобоко. И теперь: не на само изучение обращалось внимание, а только на пропаганду. Только на пропаганду. Теперь, между прочим, нужно ещё такую речь интересную поискать. Я читала...никогда, может быть, я не читала столько, сколько я читала во время коммунистов у нас.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Потому что, я подумала так:...
David Boder: Не трогайте [неразборчиво]
Anna Paul: . . . двадцать пять лет люди живут в коммунистическом строе. Люди живут. Как-то мы должны тоже жить. Я хотела узнать, в чём же дело – что, может быть, может быть у меня неправильные взгляды, может быть я заблуждаюсь, что я другого взгляда человек. Знаете, я в школе...мы должны были завести учительскую библиотеку и всё изменить. Я массу накупила книг, массу купила детских...для детской библиотеки книг. Я сама читала день и ночь – мы должны были все учителя сдать экзамен по...эээ...по истории партии мы должны были все сдать экзамен. Но чем больше я изучала коммунизм, тем темнее становился мой горизонт, тем мне дышать становилось нечем. Я помню такой случай: одна из моих коллег – она была заведующая...эээ...Кайтселийта. Кайтселийт – это назывался наша женская организация самозащиты. [Пауза] И зная, что...конечно, что уже аресты начались, что она также будет арестована – человек она была очень нервный – она лишила себя жизни. Она отравилась. В том, что это...это неприкосновенность жилища – это только одни слова. Входят в мою квартиру и, значит, не спрашивая, можно войти в эту комнату, нельзя войти в эту комнату, говорят, что чтобы снять - у меня икона висела, - чтобы снять со стены. Я говорю так: это послужит дурным при...эээ...«К Вам приходят, - спрашивают меня, - родители сюда?» «Да, заходят ко мне родители». У меня были очень хорошие отношения, я служила восемнадцать лет в одной школе, у меня были очень хорошие отношения со всем своим районом школьным. «К Вам приходят родители?» «Да, заходят». «Если они увидят тут, что у Вас висит икона на стене, это послужит...эээ...Вы упадёте в их глазах, и это послужит дурным примером для родителей, для учеников». Я сказала так, что официально внизу, где у меня учительская комната. Моя квартира была наверху, там у меня...иконы мы должны были все снять. Между прочим, дети все эти и население, и...и лютеранское население края – они нас встретили со слезами.
David Boder: Они что?
Anna Paul: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо] Со слезами это встретили – приказ о том, что икон не должно быть в школе.
David Boder: Так у лютеранцев нет икон!
Anna Paul: Изображение Христа всё равно есть у лютеранцев. Не всегда оно называется иконой, но изображение Христа есть, да?
David Boder: Да. Ну и вот?
Anna Paul: Ну и вот, и мне приказали, значит...и в моей квартире мне приказ был дан снять икону. В моей квартире был дан приказ. Кроме того,...
David Boder: Вы сняли?
Anna Paul: Я не сняла икону.
David Boder: Так как же...?
Anna Paul: Мне был вторичный приказ. Я должна была снять. Вторая была комиссия, на проверку этого. Я должна была снять. Кроме того, я Вам ещё что могу сказать? [Длинная пауза]
David Boder: Что тогда случилось...эээ...эээ...Теперь скажите-ка, как...Я вам дам спички. Теперь расскажите, как это...Возьмите их себе.
Anna Paul: Тогда у Вас не будет.
David Boder: Скажите тогда, значит, как это дошло до ухода Советов? [Пауза]
Anna Paul: Простите, как Вы сказали?
David Boder: Потом, значит, Советы же ушли из Эстонии? Война же началась.
Anna Paul: Потом началась война, да.
David Boder: Вот теперь переходите к истории о начале войны. Что тогда?
Anna Paul: Теперь совершенно видно, кто следил за газетой, может быть...войны ждали все.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Войны...
David Boder: . . . с этого начали.
Anna Paul: Да. Войны ждали все.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Потому что, кто и...кто и понимал прекрасно, какая была мысль...какая была мысль у нем...у немцев, когда они шли, но в то же время...эээ...но этим самым они нас бы спасали от коммунизма.
Anna Paul: И люди видели, что то зло, которое с собой принесёт...принесёт немецкое владычество, оно будет всё-таки меньшим злом по сравнению с тем, которое нам принесли, стране принесли коммунисты.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Я Вам должна ещё сказать: когда пришли...когда ещё строили базы, да, то у нас...у нас ограбили страну совершенно! Потому что они накупали...они накупали по полторы дюжины мужских рубашек, они накупали по...– у нас же была свободная продажа всего, –
David Boder: Не закрывайте...
Anna Paul: . . . их дамы покупали, военные их дамы покупали, они покупали себе...дюжинами покупали они себе бельё. Между прочим, у них ничего не было. Потому что, в одной мастерской, где мне шили несколько лет подряд – хозяйка этой мастерской рассказывала, - что дамы их приходили и просили пойти её, потому что не знают названия ни наших материй. Им наши фасоны были совершенно незнакомы. Теперь, факты я Вам расскажу такие: они...они подбирали бумажки конфетные и упаковки шоколадные где-нибудь, потому что они не видали таких бумаг. И они спрашивали, что: «Неужели в такой бумаге у вас у...упаковка?!» «Потому что, как же вы упаковываете?» «А мы должны с собой брать кусок газеты. Если [слово неразборчиво ] мы несём под мышкой, когда едем в трамвае. Потому что бумаги у нас...у нас вообще нет». Они удивлялись всему. Они удивлялись возможности купить полкило колбасы! Потому что они покупали всё время только по граммам.
David Boder: [In English] This ends Spool 140. Ah,...an interview with Ms. Anna Paul which we will continue on Spool 141 taken at Lohengrin Camp, in Munich, September [unintelligible] September the 21st, 1946. I am beginning to mix all my languages. Illinois Institute of Technology, wire recording.
David Boder: Spool 9-141A, Anna Paul. The same person goes in the book I Did Not Interview the Dead as Anna Prest. November the 7th, 1950. Chicago. Boder.
David Boder: Munich, September 21st, 1946, Camp Lohengrin, camp for displaced Baltics. The interview is an Estonian teacher Ms. Anna Paul. She continues now with her story which we have recorded on Spool numer 140.
David Boder: [In Russian] Значит, Вы, пожалуйста, скажите мне вот что: значит, Вы говорили относительно оценки войны. Вы знали цели Гитлера, но Вы думали [неразборчиво]
Anna Paul: Этим самым мы знали, что...этим самым мы знали, что они [очень тихо, помехи]
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Знали. Но мы знали, что этим самым мы освободимся.
David Boder: Значит, Вы не понимали, что Гитлер не может выиграть?
Anna Paul: [очень тихо, помехи] он не может выиграть.
David Boder: Значит, Вы...
Anna Paul: [неразборчиво] Мы знали, что можно освободиться от этого ада, который...который, в который мы попали.
David Boder: Но Вы же попали из огня в полымя!
Anna Paul: Мы ещё не знали, что будет. Мы ещё не знали, что когда война [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так, ну, хорошо. Значит, тогда расскажите, как ушли Советы и как пришли немцы.
Anna Paul: Когда началась...по радио мы узнали, что...по радио советскому узнали, что были обстреляны города: Киев, Харьков и даже более восточные города, я сейчас не могу сказать. Шесть городов было обстреляно.
David Boder: Не важно. Не надо.
Anna Paul: Это мы узнали, что началась война. И вот тогда...тогда самые ужасные были времена для эстонского народа. Массовые увозы. Это было четырнадцатого и пятнадцатого июля.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, сильные помехи]
Anna Paul: [Неразборчиво, сильные помехи]
David Boder: Куда их увозили?
Anna Paul: Массовые увозы в Советский Союз.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Советское радио сообщало, что...что оно...это одна из забот советского правительства об эстонском народе. Нас не оставить [неразборчиво] Гитлера. Нам было сказано. Увозы эти совершались так: ночью, в течение всех суток, приезжал автомобиль, [неразборчиво] одним давалось двадцать минут на сборы, другим давалось полчаса.
David Boder: Милиционеры были эстонские?
Anna Paul: Милиционеры были русскими.
David Boder: Русскими.
Anna Paul: И к этому времени – как потом узнали – триста человек было чекистов в Эстонию отправлено, которые эту работу произвели.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Одной семье давалось норма [неразборчиво] и большая была - это шесть пудов с собой взять можно было. Шесть пудов – это шесть раз по шестнадцать кило.
David Boder: Да, вот хорошо.
Anna Paul: Да. Другим не давалось [неразборчиво] с собой. [Неразборчиво] Были такие случаи, что в семье мёртвое тело лежало. Кто-нибудь мёртвый. Были такие. [Неразборчиво] говорили: «Дайте хоть похоронить мёртвого!» [Неразборчиво] и говорили, что другие похоронят. В моей знакомой семье двое детей было. Муж был арестован раньше. Это был инспектор гимназии. [Пауза] И ребёнок страдал от воспаления лёгких, температура 40. Ребёнок был оставлен в кровати, а семья была отправлена на вокзал. Эшелоны стояли на вокзале. [Неразборчиво] Жара была непереносимая. Людям не давали воды. Людям не давали. После уже этого, доктор, знакомый рассказывал, что он должен был осматривать эшелоны. И он, пройдя несколько вагонов, он упал в обморок. [Неразборчиво] Несколько людей [неразборчиво] в этих эшелонах, они не могли [неразборчиво]. В эти вагоны товарные загоняли до...загоняли по...восьмидесяти человек народа. Людям не было места сидеть, и люди были вынуждены стояли. Теперь...теперь нужно сказать отношение народа оставшегося. Совершенно не...
David Boder: А Вы остались каким образом?
Anna Paul: Я...мне сообщили, меня не было дома, я была в лесу.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Только благодаря этому.
Anna Paul: Только благодаря этому. У меня сынишка был, мы с сынишкой были в лесу.
David Boder: Так, а муж?
Anna Paul: Он был раньше арестован.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: [Неразборчиво] целая колона была, люди, крестьяне, на повозках подвозили хлеба, когда эшелон стоял на вокзалах ещё. Подвозили, когда...когда спрашивали комм...милиционеры «Кому?» [неразборчиво], то они сказали «Все наши родные, кто страдает!» Это наш народ так говорил. Совершенно незнакомые старались передать, никаких передач не принимали.
Anna Paul: Не смотря на то, что маленькие дети. Иногда...иногда, если человек был на службе, один отец семьи, то семья увозилась, уже была на вокзале. Приходили за отцом, говорили, что: «Что ты не идёшь домой [неразборчиво]?» Не доходя до дому, его также - в чём он был – его также увозили на вокзал. О судьбе этих людей мы ничего не знаем. О судьбе их ничего не знаем. Из одного нашего города, из Дорпата, было увезено двадцать тысяч народу.
David Boder: Вы, между прочим, профессора Пузепа знали в Юрьеве?
Anna Paul: Не знала.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]...
Anna Paul: Это психиатр?
David Boder: Психиатр-невролог.
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: И что с ним случилось?
Anna Paul: Я не могу точно сказать. Я в последний раз...но я не могу даже сказать. Но я знала, даже лично знала профессора Пузепа. Я знаю, что он не жив.
David Boder: Так. Ну, и вот...
Anna Paul: Значит, мы щас коснулись отправки эшелонов, да?
David Boder: Да.
Anna Paul: Это такова была забота...эээ...советского правительства об эстонском народе. Теперь...нужно ещё...вот такой случай я Вам расскажу: когда советские войска...эээ...между прочим, такая вещь была. Вагоны эти – кто знал, - они были заранее заготовлены. И...у...через неделю должен был отпр...второй эшелон быть. Но уже помешала война. И один...один из комиссаров выразился так: «Сначала мы вывозим свиней, а потом будем вывозить баранов».
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Это были слова...это передал мне рабочий, который в это время на вокзале работал.
David Boder: Ну, вот...
Anna Paul: Так что второй эшелон не состоялся, увоз во второй раз только потому, что помешала война. И, значит, уезжали все эти...чиновники, значит, уезжали и отступали войска. Теперь нужно рассказать об отступлении войск. Ведь были окружены. Вы...по карте представляете, да? Псков, Остов – это уже были там немцы, немцы туда вошли, да? Здесь...ммм...часть войск советских осталась. Эти войска шли без своих командиров. Солдаты шли одни. Они шли босые, ни подмёток, ни сапог не было.
David Boder: А куда ж командиры делись?
Anna Paul: Они убежали раньше. Войска...войска были голодные. Они у всех просили хлеба, они просили...они...они меняли свою последнюю рубашку – были очень жаркие дни – они называют её майками, лёгкими рубашками, что «Возьми майку, дайте только хлеба». Так отступали войска. Многие их них оставались совсем. Многие оставались в Эстонии и поступали крестьянами – это было время сенокоса – и только за хлеб, чтобы только, говорят [неразборчиво] «Через несколько лет хоть сытым быть, я буду вам работать, - говорит, - как вол», помогать нашим крестьянам косить.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Чтобы только быть сытым. И вот они много-много рассказывали. Они говорили, что они снова пробуждаются к жизни, когда видели положение нашего эстонского крестьянина, как наш крестьянин эстонский живёт. Когда они рассказывали о жизни в колхозах, один из них...он оказался простым рабочим. То есть крестьянином [неразборчиво] у себя дома, на родине. И он такой случай рассказал. У них в колхозе...у них в колхозе сыну была дана такая задача: чтобы точно знать, сколько рабочих дней в известный период времени, сколько они получили, и сколько приходится на один рабочий день. Мальчик спросил у матери точные данные. Когда мать ему точные данные дала – сколько они получают...сколько было рабочих день...дней за известный период, сколько получили в один рабочий день,- то когда мальчик свою эту домашнюю работу представил в школе, то мать была арестована.
Anna Paul: Потому что она должна была знать, опять таки, нужные или угодные кому-то данные ребёнку [неразборчиво, очень тихо].
David Boder: Так. Значит?
Anna Paul: [Неразборчиво] Знаете, так много можно рассказывать. Я не знаю, может Вы сами вопросы задавайте.
David Boder: Нет, я не хочу. Вы и так...эээ...хорошо идёте. Теперь я хочу слышать что-то...что-нибудь о пребывании немцев.
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Да. [Пауза] Когда...эээ...когда Советские...те Советские войска, которые остались у нас, они...они окружены были немцами, они не могли...не знали, куда деться. Они находились в лесах. [Пауза] Некоторые выползали...голод заставлял выползать из лесов. С некоторыми из таких и мне приходилось говорить. При...приходилось говорить...они спрашивали, что...куда им попасть и куда им лучше пройти, потому что, если...
David Boder: Это немцы говорили?
Anna Paul: Нет, это советские оставшиеся...
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: . . . что если их правительство узнает, что они здесь в плену и окружены, не делают попытки к выходу, то семья будет расстреляна. Один был молодой, говорит, что: «У меня жена и трое детей. Они все погибнут, если узнают, что...если узнают, что я в плену или в окружении и не делаю попытки к...не делаю попытки к выходу». Я ему тогда начинаю говорить: «За что вы будете воевать? За что вы это дальше будете воевать?!» Он говорит, что: «Мы же освобождаем, мы же освобождаем...Европу освобождаем от тоталитарного режима».
David Boder: Это...советские люди?
Anna Paul: Это советские люди говорят. Я сказала, что...да, «Мы же вас пришли тоже освободить». Я сказала ему, что: «Мы вас не ждали, что мы же тихо и мирно жили. А сейчас, - говорю – побыв здесь год, вы оставили нас, страну разорённую, и вы оставили только вдов и сирот. У нас оставили». И после моих разговоров с ним, он несколько времени...он...по соседству жил здесь, он никуда пока не пошел. Он оставался [неразборчиво], потому что [неразборчиво] литература. У нас была свободно литература советская. Я не могу сказать, конечно, не вся, но многие книги...книги...литература, они у нас были допущены, они у нас в библиотеках были. Но там они читали только коммунистическую литературу. И я знаю, как воспитывается советский человек, начиная с самого первого возраста. Я Вам рассказала, какие учебники были в школе, да?
David Boder: Хорошо. Теперь, так как я хочу Ваши личные...эээ...переживания...Теперь расскажите мне, как немцы вошли, и что потом произошло.
Anna Paul: [Пауза]...и во всём объёме! Всю эту жизнь при немцах я, конечно, Вам не могу рассказать, потому что я жила чисто своей...своей жизнью, какая, ну...
David Boder: Нет, я только хочу Ваше личное положение и...с тех пор, когда немцы пришли до тех пор, когда немцы ушли.
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: Хорошо.
Anna Paul: [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Немцы пришли в Ревель когда? [Пауза] Или в Эстонию.
Anna Paul: В Эстонию они пришли [неразборчиво] это было [пауза] приблизительно в июле месяце [неуверенно].
David Boder: Хорошо. Ну, что тогда произошло?
David Boder: Хорошо, мадам Пауль, вот дайте мне обзор о положении в Эстонии во время немцев или Ваше же...личном положении во время немцев.
Anna Paul: Во всём объёме! Во всём объёме в государстве?!
David Boder: Не, не, не. Дайте...Я не прошу Вас государственно...дайте мне такую же историю, в том же объёме, как Вы дали мне об оккупации русской.
Anna Paul: Так. [Пауза] Эстония – страна сельскохозяйственная. Значит, отозваться особенно могло пребывание немцев на сельском хозяйстве.
David Boder: Нет, я хочу не экономической. Я хочу, как оно отозвалось на людях, которые там жили. Политически – как Вас...насколько Вы были свободны? Насколько они обращались с людьми? Ведь Вы и, когда говорили о Советах, говорили только о том, что...о человеческой стороне.
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: Вот Вы перейдите на человеческую сторону здесь.
Anna Paul: Я Вас уже предупредила, что так много нужно рассказать, что я можно [неразборчиво, очень тихо]
David Boder: Ага. Видите ли, Вы поймите, что это будет...как сказать, вполне unbalanced, если Вы мне рассказали обо всем, что происходило при русских...
Anna Paul: Так.
David Boder: . . . и не хотите ничего рассказать о том, что было при немцах.
Anna Paul: Боже сохрани, почему я не хочу! Я не знаю, с чего начать, потому что...
David Boder: Возьмите эпизоды, как они...
Anna Paul: Да.
David Boder: Во-первых, как они отнеслись к Вашей школе?
Anna Paul: Расскажу Вам об этом. Школа моя...двухэтажное здание было, наверху была моя квартира, внизу были классы. Нужно было как раз поместить здесь...разместиться части немецкой в школе. Мне это было...Я не знаю, кто приехал, кто-то из их начальства, как они сказали, на автомобиле приехал. Мне сказали, что вот. Это было до начала занятий. Занятия начались...должны были начаться занятия у нас...эээ...в конце сентября, а в начале сентября мне было сказано, что 8-9 сентября школа моя будет занята немецкими войсками. Я потом спросила, так что сколько мне времени дадут на то, чтобы мне нужно было подыскать другое помещение. Мне сказали, что: «Два-три дня Вам будет достаточно?» Я сказала, что немножко мало, потому что мне нужно ехать [неразборчиво], и подводы найти, чтобы школьное всё имущество перевезти. Ну, согласились мы на [неразборчиво] три-четыре дня [неразборчиво]. Дали мне...эээ...возможность отправиться в наше головное управление, дали мне...назначили мне 15-20 лошадей подвод, и я должна была найти помещение, классы разместить. Я тогда спросила, что лич...что квартира моя. Я должна была тоже съехать через четыре дня или моя квартира остаётся. Мне сказали что: «Ваша квартира остаётся неприкосновенна», и я в своей квартире жила до последнего времени.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: Потом, со временем уже, когда их часть увеличилась, то из своей квартиры я им комнаты [неразборчиво], ну, и сократила [неразборчиво]. Но квартира была неприкосновенна.
David Boder: Ну, да. На каком языке Вы начали преподавать?
Anna Paul: На том же самом языке – на русском, на котором школа раньше велась. Они лично никакого абсолютно отношения к школе не...в школу абсолютно не вмешивались! В школу абсолютно не вмешивались. Очень охотно рассказывали о положении своей школы, очень удивлялись нашим длинным каникулам в Эстонии. Потому что у них в Германии в начале вообще не было никаких летних каникул, может...[неразборчиво] может только перерыв был у них на одну неделю, они говорили. Меня это, как учителя интересовало, что как же крестьянские дети, наши дети, помогают родителям? Они сказали, что у них настолько строгие законы, что родители уже с этим свыклись и привыкли, что дети и летом ходят в школу. Только можно [неразборчиво] они мне так сказали...мне, как учительнице, меня положение школы в Германии очень интересовало. Самой мне в Германии никогда быть не приходилось, только знала литературу о положении в школах в...во всей Европе, читала...только по литературе, а в живую таких рассказов никогда нигде не слыхала. Так они тогда рассказывают, что занятия начинаются у них летом с 6 часов утра...
David Boder: Мы знаем о немецких школах.
Anna Paul: Да, и так далее.
David Boder: Хорошо, теперь, что они сделали вообще с мирным населением?
Anna Paul: [Пауза] Мирное население как жило, так и...мирное население как оно жило, так оно и жило. Только, конечно, сложно было...сложно было выплачивать вот эти нормы. Я считаю, что об этом положении [неразборчиво] о выплате норм, это Вам бы надо более...
David Boder: Какие это были нормы?
Anna Paul: Это нормы были сельскохозяйственные, да? [Неразборчиво] человек, который имел хозяйство. У меня своего хозяйства нет. Я могу сказать так, что одна крестьянка мне сказала, что: «Сдать масла на ту норму, которая нужна - это когда корова должна давать не молоко, доиться не молоком, а только масло. Только тогда я могу эту норму сдать».
David Boder: Так. Что они сделали с евреями?
Anna Paul: [Пауза] У нас в Эстонии я Вам не могу сказать. Но у меня были родные в Латвии, вот про Латвию я могу сказать.
David Boder: Так.
Anna Paul: В городе Риге, там особая часть города, где раньше мы ходили, и вдруг мне говорят, что там пройти нельзя. Почему? А я этого не знала совершенно.
David Boder: А Вы были в Риге тогда?
Anna Paul: Нет. Я была у себя, но я Вам должна сказать, что в это время – начало, когда приходили немцы – я жила не в городе, а в месте моей службы, оно было вне городского района, да? И когда я поехала в Ригу, мне, значит, знакомые [неразборчиво] пройти, что через этот район идти уже нельзя, потому что он окружен проволокой. Мне мои знакомые говорят, что такое проволока и вот тут-то они мне весь ужас этой картины, знаете, и рассказали. Я...об отношении немцев к еврейскому народу до тех пор, пока не оказалась в столице Латвии, не слышала. И нужно Вам сказать, что когда они рассказывали...когда немцы рассказывали о положении школы, я их с интересом слушала. Но с ними нельзя было – если вы не хотели поссориться – нельзя было коснуться...эээ...коснуться вопроса о...еврейского вопроса. С ними нельзя было коснуться, потому что тогда вы будете сразу врагом. Я сказала, что я не вмешиваюсь в дела Гитлера и в дела вашей политики, но я сказала, что это бесчеловечно. Она невозможна, я сказала. Я сказала, что...что это же...что это невозможное отношение. Вы знаете, но к такому откровенному моему мнению они [неразборчиво] только нажила себе врагов. Это я понимаю.
David Boder: Но в этом отношении, конечно, разницы не было между большевиками и ни...ими?
Anna Paul: Но большевики не делали исключений...они не делали исключений...эээ...[стук в дверь]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Ms. Anna Paul simply because she has no more time. She is busy and we will change to another interviewee. September the 21st, 1946, Camp Lohengrin.
David Boder: Remarks to the duplicate spool: This concludes the interview with Mrs. Anna Paul which was called in the book Anna Prest. The next section is an interview with Mrs. Sophia, who does not want to give her last name, but it seems that she later gave as Zurilis. Check Spool 9-141B. This concludes Spool 9-141A. Boder, Chicago, November the 7th, 1950.